bienvenido de vuelta vamos a hacer más
problemas de ventaja mecánica y en este
vídeo nos vamos a enfocar en poleas que
es una máquina simple vamos a tratar de
entender la ventaja mecánica que hay
detrás de este tipo de máquinas así que
empecemos con una con una polea sencilla
digamos que aquí tenemos digamos aquí
está el techo que ahí tenemos el techo
y del techo está digamos colgando está
fija una polea que es una polea
esencialmente es como una especie de
disco tenemos una especie de disco y que
este disco puede puede rotar muy bien
este disco puede rotar aquí digamos en
la pared
digamos correspondiente a esta a este
círculo es decir si si lo viéramos de
lado veríamos como como algo así verdad
algo así entonces sobre esta pared hay
una especie de canal que en donde puede
ir una cuerda y cómo está esta rueda
gira digamos puede girar con muy poquita
fricción es decir no casi no genera
fricción sobre la cuerda entonces esto
es lo que provoca es que si tenemos una
cuerda aquí
deberíamos hacerlo un poco más derechito
que tenemos
una cuerda sí
muy bien entonces si uno jala una cuerda
del lado derecho del otro lado va a
subir eso es lo que nos está provocando
esta polea sencilla ok entonces digamos
digamos que tenemos un peso del lado
izquierdo digamos de no sé cómo siempre
de 10 newtons ok tenemos aquí un peso de
10 newtons verdad entonces la pregunta
que te hago es cuál es la ventaja
mecánica
si nosotros jalamos la cuerda de este
lado digamos que digamos que jalamos así
hacia abajo
hacemos una fuerza hacia abajo al
realizar esta fuerza cuál es la ventaja
mecánica en este en este cuando cuando
trabajamos con una polea entonces para
poder responder esto o lo que es lo
mismo verdad es responder cuál es la
fuerza necesaria para elevar este peso
de 10 newtons y cuál es la fuerza que
necesito para para poder producir una
fuerza de 10 minutos pero hacia arriba
verdad y poder
este este cuerpo muy bien entonces para
poder analizar esto tenemos que ver cómo
se mueven o cómo cambian las distancias
verdad digamos digamos que tengo aquí un
punto verdad siempre siempre vamos a
tratar de fijar puntos y ver cómo es que
se mueven al aplicar yo esta fuerza
digamos que se recorrió una distancia de
muy bien entonces este punto se recorrió
una distancia no sé una distancia fija
pero si nosotros jalamos la cuerda y
movemos esta distancia quiere decir que
de este lado digamos si teníamos este
punto entonces se recorrió la misma
distancia hacia arriba verdad
esencialmente la misma distancia
entonces si tenemos las distancias
iguales y digamos aquí tenemos una
fuerza de diez newtons pues la fuerza
que necesito aquí jalar hacia abajo es
exactamente igual verdad porque las
distancias son iguales y sabemos que hay
una conservación del trabajo entonces
recordemos que la fuerza
entrada digamos por la distancia de
entrada que correspondería a esta
distancia debe ser igual a la fuerza de
salida por la distancia de salida si las
distancias son iguales quieren decir que
las fuerzas tienen que ser iguales muy
bien entonces esto solo es por la
conservación de la energía o la
conservación digamos del trabajo verdad
entonces si si él si las fuerzas son
iguales pues la ventaja mecánica es una
verdad porque la ventaja mecánica era
era era la división entre la fuerza de
entrada entre la fuerza de salida más
bien al revés verdad la ventaja mecánica
es la fuerza de salida entre la fuerza
de entrada y si estas dos son iguales
pues esto no esto nos da uno bien
entonces ya que sabemos esto pues
podemos ver que realmente las poleas no
no son una no son muy interesantes solo
lo que estamos logrando es que con una
polea en vez de subir
jalar un peso digamos hacia arriba lo
que podemos hacer es mejor jalar la
cuerda hacia abajo a lo mejor es más
fácil para nuestro cuerpo hacerlo de
esta forma o no sé realmente no tenemos
una utilidad en términos de d
de fuerzas verdad porque la ventaja
mecánica es 1 pero a lo mejor es más
cómodo calar la cuerda así que vamos a
ver otro ejemplo en donde si tengamos
una ventaja mecánica positiva digamos
que tengo aquí dos poleas digamos aquí
hay una polea
muy bien y más o menos por aquí vamos a
tener
otra polea que quizás debería hacerlo un
poquito mejor
algo así ahí está bueno ustedes imaginen
que es realmente un círculo muy bien y
ahora tenemos una cuerda también
que cuelga de aquí
se enrolla en esta parte de la polea y
luego se enrolla en la otra pelea
muy bien y finalmente está atada al
techo muy bien aquí está fijo al techo
ok entonces vamos a hacer la misma
pregunta si nosotros jalamos de este
lado y digamos que tenemos colgando por
aquí un peso de 10 mil tons
y aquí tenemos un peso de 10 newtons yo
joven no es una masa es un peso de 10
minutos aunque el peso es una fuerza
entonces digamos que queremos ver cuál
es la ventaja mecánica al subir este
cuerpo entonces para poder analizar esto
hacemos el digamos la misma técnica
fijemos un punto aquí y al aplicar una
fuerza digamos no sé que de hecho es la
que no sabemos
digamos que movimos este punto dos
metros verdad dos metros ahora bien cómo
es que se mueve del lado izquierdo pues
esencialmente la cuerda también se tiene
que recorrer dos metros pero ahora
tenemos que dar toda esta vuelta
entonces primero recorrerá un metro
digamos no sé de aquí un metro y luego
otro metro así que en realidad estas
estos dos pedazos de cuerda se recortan
un metro cada uno
ok digamos su longitud se disminuye un
metro en cada lado y así estos dos
metros acumulados nos dan estos dos
metros que desplazamos hacia abajo donde
aplicamos nuestra fuerza muy bien
entonces cuál sería el trabajo generado
vamos a ver eso el trabajo de salida
digamos el trabajo de salida que
esencialmente es el resultado de haber
jalado fue que subimos un metro subimos
un metro esta polea verdad perdón a este
cuerpo porque si recorrimos un metro de
cada lado entonces esto subió un metro
también entonces este cuerpo subió un
metro pero tiene un peso de 10 newtons
quiere decir que el trabajo es fuerza
por distancia y estos serían de 10
minutos por un
muy bien entonces esto que nos da pues
10 por 1 son 10 y newtons por metros son
giles verdad entonces tenemos un trabajo
generado de 10
jules muy bien este es el trabajo de
salida digamos entonces cómo calcular y
amos el trabajo de entrada el trabajo de
entrada pues tienen que ser exactamente
10 hills por la ley de la conservación
de la energía muy bien entonces nuestra
fuerza de entrada que era lo que
queríamos saber cuánta fuerza teníamos
que aplicar aquí para poder elevar este
cuerpo de 10 newtons de peso la fuerza
por la distancia que en este caso son
dos deberían ser igual bueno es justo
nuestro trabajo y que vimos que son 10
jules verdad entonces si dividimos de
ambos lados entre 2 y aquí de hecho
adquieran dos metros verdad entonces si
dividimos entre dos metros nos queda que
la fuerza de entrada o lo que hay que
aplicar es 5 y jules entre metros nos da
newtons verdad entonces tenemos 5
newtons de fuerza que hay que aplicar al
inicio o hay que hay que aplicar o que
hay que jalar para poder elevar este
cuerpo un metro entonces si te das
cuenta tuvimos que aplicar la mitad de
la fuerza porque esto eran 10 minutos y
aquí aplicamos 5 newtons sin embargo
lo que tenemos que hacer es aplicarla
por el doble de la distancia verdad aquí
aplicamos dos metros y subió sólo un
metro entonces nuestra fuerza de entrada
fueron cinco jules mientras que la
fuerza de salida la fuerza de salida
pues esto es el trabajo dividido entre
la distancia por la distancia era un
metro así que estos son diez minutos
aquí me aquí me equivoqué él no son
giles
la fuerza no se mide se mide en newtons
verdad entonces como calculábamos la
ventaja mecánica la ventaja mecánica se
calculaba como la fuerza de salida entre
la fuerza de entrada y si la fuerza de
salida eran 10 newtons y la de entrada
eran 5 newtons entonces tenemos que la
ventaja mecánica es exactamente 2 muy
bien ahora vamos a hacer un último
ejemplo con otra máquina que no son
nuestros digamos ni siquiera un arreglo
de poleas sino vamos a considerar un
plano inclinado y a mí al inicio me
costaba trabajo entender por qué una un
plano inclinado podría ser una máquina
esencialmente sólo tenemos una tabla
verdad
una tabla con una inclinación digamos de
30 grados y realmente esto es una
máquina porque vamos a ver que en efecto
genera una ventaja mecánica muy bien
entonces si nosotros tenemos nuestro
nuestro cuerpo aquí que digamos que
tenemos nuestro cuerpo aquí y queremos
llevarlo hasta el otro extremo queremos
llevarlo hasta el otro extremo y digamos
que hay una distancia aquí esta
distancia
mide de ok entonces vamos a ver qué
tanto nos ayuda a empujar una caja sobre
un plano inclinado a sol o más bien cómo
sería esto
es decir cuál es la diferencia de
empujar esta caja a lo largo de todo
este plano digamos algo así y cuál es la
diferencia que si yo hubiera cargado la
caja empezando de este vértice del
triángulo y digamos lo hubiera jalado de
alguna forma hacia arriba ok entonces
vamos a ver nosotros sabemos qué
utilizando las funciones trigonométricas
si esta es la distancia de nosotros
sabemos que el seno de 30 grados es el
cateto opuesto sobre la hipotenusa que
en este caso mide de verdad entonces
esta altura que es el cateto opuesto
será esencialmente de x seno de 30
grados ahora bien seno de 30 grados y
sería bueno que lo recordarás es
justamente un medio así que vamos a
quitar todo esto y sólo vamos a dejar el
un medio si esto a lo mejor te parece un
poco extraño te invito a que revises las
los vídeos de funciones trigonométricas
entonces pero esto era un medio por la
distancia de ahora bien como calculamos
la energía potencial que tendría la caja
si está en su punto máximo pues la
energía potencial si se acuerdan es la
masa por la aceleración por la altura
masa aceleración por altura pero la masa
por la aceleración es justamente la
fuerza qué
digamos el peso y aquí dijimos que eran
10 newtons verdad es la misma cajita que
hace rato entonces esta masa por
aceleración son 10 newtons por la altura
que es un medio de d así que esto
simplemente será 10 newtons
por un medio de esto y esto que nos da
son 10 entre 2 son 5 newtons por
distancia que son metros así que son 5
de esta distancia de por qué son
jules verdad estamos midiendo la energía
en jules y esta es la energía potencial
muy bien
y por la ley de la conservación nosotros
sabemos que la fuerza de entrada digamos
la fuerza que hay que aplicar por
nuestra distancia debe ser igual a la
energía del sistema que son 5 de jules
verdad así que podemos dividir entre d
de ambos lados y nos queda que la fuerza
de entrada la fuerza que hay que aplicar
para poder mover esta caja es de 5 jules
y justamente tuvimos una ventaja
mecánica verdad tuvimos una ventaja
mecánica porque lo que teníamos eran
diez eran diez minutos verdad
nuevamente teníamos 10 newtons y
dividimos entre la de entrada que son 5
newtons y nuestra ventaja mecánica es 2